I have no idea oh it's on now
there we go sorry I tried a minute ago
and it wasn't on so hello I'm Martin
doll and this is the last talk of the
conference or one of the last talks the
conference this is all about why I'm not
leaving net just for a change because
hands up who's read a why I'm leaving
net blog post anytime in the last 20
years yeah
people people get all they know they get
stressed with dotnet and throw their
toys out of the pram and go I'm stomping
off to another ecosystem or they go Oh
shiny thing and I have to go chasing
after something else and there's lots of
places that they go and things that they
do and reasons that they leave and I've
kind of stuck with it all this time and
there have been good times and there
have been bad times and there has been
silver light but that's currently I
think dotnet is possibly the best it's
ever been and I wanted to show you a few
other things that I think are really
cool about it
so nothing's going to go too in depth I
know at this stage of the conference
everyone's kind of fair there was a
party last night and you don't want me
to be sitting here going so if we tweak
this XML file here we can change the way
that bytecode is generated so I'm not
going to do any of that I'm just going
to show you a bunch of cool stuff that
I've been playing with or that I've been
monitoring the progress of and hopefully
give you some ideas of stuff that you
can go and play with and I promise I
won't clap again because that was really
an out all right so the problem is and
this is true in software development
generally the grass is always greener on
the other side of the fence so you're
sitting there doing whatever you're
doing and whatever you're doing it in
and then you read something and you go
you know like 10 years ago it was rails
rails you can build a whole web
application just by typing commands and
then go into production and get 50
million dollars from Silicon Valley
venture capitalists even in dotnet
itself you're kind of going all entity
framework but there's
dapper all dapper but then there's
Petter poco and stuff so and developers
are notoriously fickle people and they
will jump to other things for a variety
of different reasons one of the ones
that we've seen a lot of over the last
five years or so is people are going oh
no js' lots of people are kind of dived
onto no js' and gone performance it's
it's web-scale nodejs is the fastest web
framework you just use Express and you
throw things together and it's all
JavaScript on the server and JavaScript
on the client and it's really really
fast and the thing is no js' is very
fast and very scalable at the things
that no js' is very fast and very
scalable for which is getting stuff from
one place and sending it to another
place that's it it's basically a
networking protocol as soon as you say
to no js' generate me a gooood it goes
right everything's stopped I'm
generating a gooood hold on for two
milliseconds or I've done it and then
everything else gets to carry on I wrote
a web poke tracking thing for one of the
sponsors out there actually I won't name
which one and every time a request came
in it put this little 1x1 pixel on to
the page but every time it did that it
generated 3uu IDs as they're called in
load and it would only serve 800
requests a second because generating you
you IDs is a slow operation and it was
doing it's single threaded so what it's
doing it that's it CPU bound it's locked
up but people think that asp net is slow
and asp net the full fat framework asp
net is not great and running it on mono
it's not great but now we have asp net
core and this is the tech empower
benchmarks if you don't know what these
are these guys came up with a series of
different benchmark applications and
they implement them in lots and lots and
lots of different stacks frameworks
languages all this sort of stuff and
then they compare them and they produce
this benchmark chart every three months
or so and you can contribute your own
things
a asp net core running on linux is on
this chart and it's in about 15 place
I think asp net core on linux on the
hardware that they're using will do 1.7
million requests a second
that's asp.net core 2.0 running on
dotnet core 2.0 running on a linux
server that's fast
okay the stuff above it there's some
Java things up there there's Metis and
Java we're catching up to Java but
they've got niño and they've got cool
things but there's some stuff coming in
dotnet core 2.1 that's going to help us
catch up a bit further and we're gonna
jump up that list a little bit further
the thing right at the top is C and how
do you compete with C you know someone's
gonna go I'm writing my web application
in C and C++ you're just gonna go right
fine
that's that's gonna be really fast until
it crashes because you forgot to D
alakazam memory so yes asp net core is
is very fast or at least it is for
plaintext stuff as soon as you get into
some of the other benchmarks like JSON
serialization or anything that does
database access it starts to slow down
again because kestrel which is the asp
net core web server has had a lot of
very clever people come there going oh
we can treat all the HTTP methods get
put post patched delete options whatever
they're all less than 8 bytes so
therefore we can turn them into a long
and do a switch statement against them
it's just bonkers stuff so yeah that's
nice so but that's getting faster but
the rest of the framework is still
lagging behind it does lots of
allocations and everything but they're
starting to introduce a bunch of
primitives into dotnet
call 2.1 and some more language features
into seizure knob 7.2 they're gonna make
things even faster so don't make call
2.1 we've got this new thing called span
of T so instead of having byte arrays
and passing by two rays around which is
a heap allocated object we have this
span of T and you can have a span of
byte that either points to a byte array
or a subset of a byte array or some
unmanaged memory that you've got using
unsafe code and
asking for a pointer and P invoking
malloc or other sorts of things and span
is our struct and so you can pass it
around and it doesn't cause any heap
allocations and this is providing the
ability to make some very very fast code
and they've introduced they've added
support for span of byte to a lot of
things that previously took a byte array
so you can now say copy this span of
byte onto a string directly and we've
got there's a utf-8 formatting class
where you can say take this integer and
turn it into a utf-8 string version so
you've got 42 and it writes that bytes
for 4 & 2 to the stream and so we can do
a lot of things without hitting the
garbage collector and the heap at all
which makes things really really fast
and C sharps got support for these this
span type
it's got ref locals and ref returns so
we don't have to copy values as much
we're getting some really really
low-level hard core primitives that are
letting the guys who write the plumbing
code that we use to build our
applications make that plumbing code
incredibly light and fast and so we're
gonna see performance just getting even
better from now on
you've got in parameters and read-only
struct as well which is great for kinda
safe programming you can say I created
this struct you can't change it if you
want to change it make another copy of
it with different values and that sort
of thing so we can enforce that now and
then you see our page we've got nullable
reference types where so you think your
code is null safe and it's not going to
crash and it's not going to give any
null reference exceptions when c-sharp 8
comes along it's going to be a compiler
flag to turn this on and it will be off
by default but they're gonna let you
turn it on and then try and compile your
code and it will tell you every single
place I really don't want to do this at
work every single place in your code
where you could potentially get a null
reference exception I guarantee you
there's going to be hundreds of them
just set aside a sprint or two to fix
them all so yes I was sort of learning
about all this stuff and reading about
it and I thought I want to try and
experiment
I've got this theory okay when I create
microservices what I tend to have is you
have posts and puts and patches that are
coming in and you get the object and you
validate the object and maybe send
maksim errors or maybe store it into a
database like MS sequel server or
Postgres or my sequel or whatever it is
so for the right side that's that's
great and you don't get rights happening
that often be you get a lot of queries
90% of database accesses or queries
people want to know what date is in the
database and what those queries are
doing in a dotnet application is they're
going right get the data out of the
database if you want it to be fast to
use dapper and you say dapper turn this
DB data reader into objects and so
dapper creates a thousand objects in
memory and then it passes them over to
Jason net and Jason net turns them all
into utf-8 bytes of Jason and then sends
that down the string and I thought what
if you take that middle step out what if
you just go from the DB data reader and
just write it straight to the stream as
JSON so I wrote this in called B line
and where are we
so be lying basically does this and be
line only works on dotnet core 2.1
because it's using these spam types and
everything okay so we've got we've got a
road an object writer so you give this
DB data reader and it turns it into a
JSON object and you can see that what we
pass in to this thing here is a memory
of byte so memory is like spam but it's
a reference type because there are so
many restrictions on what you can do
with span so you have this memory thing
that makes it a bit easier so we passed
this memory thing in here but and the
rows here realizer gets this span of
byte which is so new that every single
idea I have Visual Studio 2017 preview
15.6 the actual visual studio JetBrains
rider up-to-date version by the way if
you can't ride ride and give it a try it
is really awesome and Visual Studio code
all say you can't use a span of byte
funnily enough when I go to the command
line and say dotnet build it goes yes
point so ignore this ignore the red
squiggles but yes so we have this span
it comes in and we say right I want to
get the first two bytes so I'm going to
do buffets slice and that creates
another span still no allocations
because it's just returned another span
that's a subset of the previous span and
then we write things across to this and
the writers are all just let me find a
writer so yeah there's an in 32 writer
and what that's basically doing is using
this utf-8 formatter to format an int 32
onto a byte buffer so there's no two
string involved at any point here it is
just going this is how this would look
as utf-8 bytes there's a utf-16
formatter as well and a utf-32 formatter
I don't know what they're for what the
hell are we still doing with either of
those you TFS what are they I invented
you tf2 five six which is 256 bit
encoding which is essentially large
enough for every single photograph or
picture or anything ever taken in the
history of my
kind to be encoded in a font useful
right yeah so yes and I wrote this and
it's got these fans and things all over
the place and then somebody else
contributed back some some additional
refinements to it guy called Tim C would
you may know him on Twitter he's yeah
he's he's all about the where am I going
I don't know all about the optimizations
and all this other stuff the other the
other guy is Ben Adams who contributed
an awful lot of the fixes to kestrel so
yes if I go into tests and beelined
benchmarks and artifacts and results so
I'm using this thing called benchmark
net as if you haven't seen benchmark net
yet if you're kind of writing your
low-level stuff and you want to know
which is faster this way of doing it all
that way of doing it or I think I've
optimized this but I don't know
benchmark net lets you write performance
unit tests basically you can say do this
and it does it like a thousand times and
it does the other one a thousand times
and it takes care of warm-up and it
watches memory allocations and all this
sort of stuff
and then you can go right so this way
takes a little bit longer but uses less
memory or this way is faster and uses
less memory and so forth so we used
benchmark net to benchmark this going
straight from a DB data reader to the
network stream and compared it to dapper
and entity framework and the results
came out as n/a which is interesting
okay
taking dapper and Jason dominate out of
the equation that is really annoying
that's that's worked every single time
except now this is my nd seekers
basically the B line way of doing it
this this new low performance low
overhead high performance way of doing
it is 20% faster than dapper which is
actually you're kind of like going wow
because Daffy has being the standard for
doing this sort of thing quickly and
just by taking out that step of creating
a bunch of objects that
don't really need and then turning them
into Jason and just going the shortest
possible distance between two points
we've managed to shave 20% of the time
off it also uses less than half the
memory and performance is getting
increasingly important because now we're
not sort of spinning up a big server and
running everything on a big server or
maybe a pair of service with mirroring
we're spinning up clusters of docker
servers and kubernetes clusters in the
cloud and we want to run lots and lots
and lots of different things on these
one cluster and we want to run multiple
instances of them and the more things we
can cram in the higher density we can
achieve on this kind of cluster hosting
then the less we have to pay at the end
of the month when the issuer bill comes
in or the AWS bill comes in so doing
this kind of low-level performance stuff
is actually worthwhile and I think we're
gonna see Dominic getting a lot faster
cuz of that so it's quite cool the next
thing is go a lot of people have kind of
gone running over to go and the thing
that go has going for it is native
compilation so you write the code and
you build it and it creates a native
statically linked executable that you
can just take and run on any machine
there's no runtime required you can
build it on Linux and it'll go and run
on Linux machines you can build it for
Windows that run on Windows machines
with the dot exe thing and so that's
quite cool as well and it would be nice
if we could do that in a language that
looks like it was designed after 1970
because basically go the way we make a
language like go is you put someone into
suspended animation in 1970 and then you
wake him up now and you don't tell him
about any of the developments in
programming over the last 40 years and
you say make a new programming language
so yes does anyone know what peach r1g
cock-thumb nangi tall janky troy means
any guesses I will not give up my
favorite decoration I watched the whole
film for that one slide there we go
so it would be nice if we could do
native compilation and creati cleaned
executables in dotnet and and you see
shaft write these things with generics
and you know async and awaked and all
the cool stuff that we unlink everything
that we have in in.net that makes it so
cool and we can because there's a
project that's it's not going as well as
they'd hoped and it's having some issues
but they're getting there called karate
and karate is an ahead of time
compilation runtime and compiler for
dotnet so you get your doctor
application and you compile it to
assemblies and dll's and then you pass
those assemblies to core RT and it runs
them through Ryu JIT all at the same
time it's a bit like engine ok to
remember engine from the gak and turns
them all into a single statically linked
executable file that doesn't require a
runtime and I'm going to demo this and I
am actually demoing it right now because
this slide presentation deck is running
in slighty which is my standalone
command line presentation deck thing
that I've written it's it's
semi-functional it works locally it's
supposed to be online features but
they're not working and I want to be
able to distribute this to people the
idea came from revealed is which is an
old thing and with that it's kind of
like oh really simple slide things you
can just use JavaScript on HTML or
markdown and then just launch your
slideshow when it's finally going great
how do I run this incredibly simple
slideshow thing well install mode and
you can like okay what so install node
and then install NPM and then clone this
github repository and then edit the
slides file and then do an NPM restore
and then run grunts are you just kind of
like wow so I wanted something similar
to that but where I could just put an
acci up onto github releases and people
could download that XE and run it
locally and so I have actually achieved
that using core RT if I go to my
see drive and into bin so I've got three
files here libuv dll which is what
Kestrel uses to be a web server and then
I've got slide exe which is a 23
megabyte executable file and that's it I
don't need the PDB file it's just there
because when I accidentally copied it
across it's not necessary that slide Exe
file contains the core CLR or the core
RT version of the CLR it's got the
garbage collector it doesn't have the
jitter because it doesn't need the
jitter because everything's already been
kitted and it contains native compiled
pre linked versions of all the code not
only for the.net base class library but
also for most of the asp net core
runtime it's got routing in there it's
got MVC core it's got the options
framework the configuration framework
the dependency injection framework and
it's all wrapped up into a single 2xe
file I could give you the XE and that
DLL and you put it on a machine that's
never seen net in its life and you would
run the really cool thing the thing I
love about this is I've got windows
subsystem for Linux on here and I've
installed all the necessary things on
windows subsystem for Linux and I can
use that and I can build a single
statically linked executable file which
doesn't have 2x e on the end and I can
upload that to github and anyone can
download that onto any Linux machine
that's running a reasonably up-to-date
kernel and they'll be able to launch it
as well
the only thing I can't create on this
machine is a Mac executable which
doesn't bother me so yes that's pretty
cool
the thing that's really cool about it
though ok so I'm gonna jump into stick
CLI SRC slide II okay so I'm gonna do
can everyone see the PowerShell at the
back there alright so I'm going to do
dotnet run this is how you launch this
application from the command line and
I'm gonna say use the release build I
have built this already ok so this is
just running the code that I've built it
loading up all the asp net framework and
its chitting everything and there you go
so there's a bit of a delay so if this
was just a command-line application I'd
written to do something to process a
bunch of files and produce some output
or something every time I was running it
it was going to take that long just to
get to the first line of code that I
actually wanted to run okay this slide
exe is on my path okay so this is the
natively compiled version this is the
full ASP met core framework spinning up
okay so yeah that's that's
I like that demo that's a good demo so
yeah we can do this now we can without
worrying about runtimes without worrying
about all this sort of stuff we can
create these native executables this one
is big because it's got the whole of asp
net included in it i could trim it down
i could turn on features to kind of do
aggressive tree shaking and not include
code that's not going to be used but
that's still really really alpha and it
tends to break things but if you have
I've got a simple thing that takes a
bunch of XML files that have been output
from listening to diagnostic stopwatch
and turns those into an HTML report and
that is compiled the same way and it's
five megabytes with the complete dotnet
runtime inside it as well which actually
is something that you can just go here
I'll email that to you and then email
server goes no that's an X II you're not
having that phishing
but yes so you can now create command
line applications that launch as quickly
as if they were written in C or go or
rust or anything else that is not to say
that C and rust and go don't have a
place rust in particular I am learning
rust I like it a lot there's a lot to be
said for it but I know c-sharp I know
dotnet and for me the quickest and
easiest way to write anything is like
that so that's why okay so moving on
people a lot of people jump ship to go
and do mobile development and they went
ah the future is in mobile and iPhones
mainly iPhones also Android phones but
mainly iPhones
Android users tend to steal software
whereas on iPhone users tend to pay for
it so that's where they went and at
first it was really terrible because
they had to learn objective-c any
Objective C developers in the room yeah
you know how you make Objective C you
take the best bits of small talk and the
best bits of C++ and you throw them away
and what's left is Objective C it's got
better now because they've got Swift
which is somewhere between a ripoff of
c-sharp and a ripoff of Kotlin but it's
quite nice it's better but it's still
got some pain around it if you want to
write for Android natively then you
write Java or you use Kotlin which is
now an officially supported language
which is quite nice as well but you have
to write two versions of your
application you have to write the end
the Android one with all the copling
code you have to write the iOS one with
all the swift code or you can use
JavaScript you can use things like react
native and so forth and create
applications using JavaScript and so
forth or you can use xamarin I don't
like the actual xamarin monkey I prefer
this one so now with xamarin we have
xamarin forms and i wanted to come up
here and because I have used xamarin
forms to build a couple of test
applications for some training videos
that I'm working on which aren't ready
yet which means I can't sell them to you
which means I've just wasted a couple of
days being here really I have nothing to
benefit from this but never mind that's
that's my problem not yours
but no stammering forms xamarin has been
around for a long time and you have been
able to share all your business logic
code by compiling it as a portable class
library or sharing the project but you
had to write all the UI code for android
using whatever that XML format is these
for Android and for iPhone using
interface builder and all these sorts of
things now they've got xamarin forms and
xamarin forms lets you define your UI
using zamel in a shared library and then
include that into an iPhone project and
an Android project and a uwp project and
a Mac OS project you can support all
these different these different formats
and in the latest version of end xamarin
forms it used to be that that shade
he was a portable class library hands up
who loves portable class libraries
you're a sick man single person at the
back I saw that so yeah we got dotnet
standard now which is really cool and
it's been explained previously in the
conference and so I'm not going to
explain it but I totally do understand
it honestly but so xamarin of Madoc net
standard work with sam'l and so we can
now go into visual studio and we can
create a new project
I really shouldn't start Visual Studio
live on stage during talks or we can
just open a solution that I created
earlier excuse to drink a glass of water
come on and what we have is a dotnet
standard project which has got a sam'l
in it which defines a user interface and
then we have an Android project which
literally just pulls that in and a hooks
it up to Android and we can have an iOS
project which just pulls that library in
and hooks it up to iOS and a Mac OS one
and a UWP one so because everybody wants
to write Windows Store applications
right no people so yes and I wanted to
come up here and go look I can run this
in Android and I can run it in in uwp
and it didn't work out so here it is
running in uwp this is literally just
the hello world application
I can't demo it on iOS because still to
build an iOS application you need Xcode
and to get Xcode you need Mac so you
have to have a Mac you can write it on a
Windows PC and have a Mac sitting on the
network and then use that you send the
code over and it builds it and it sends
it back and you can do that with it I
think here it is running in UWP that's
nice and easy here is the
this is the main page zamel here so yeah
we've got a label with the text hello in
DC so it's a something it's not WPF it's
not uwp it's a kind of weird subset
amalgam of various things but you define
your user interface once the nice thing
is that it then renders that like an
Android application on Android like an
iOS application on iOS like a mac o s--
application on mac and like an u WP
application so you have this one UI you
can put all your business logic internet
standard libraries the bit that's
actually specific to each platform is
very very small indeed so you can be
developing for all these platforms at
the same time except I wanted to be able
to come to just very quickly switch and
show you the same application running in
Android or the Android emulator but this
is me yesterday trying to get Android
emulation working on my laptop anyone
eating sorry yeah I can't run the
official Android emulator because I'm
running docker for Windows and docker
for Windows runs in hyper-v and hyper-v
is a hypervisor layer and when you
enable hyper-v in Windows 10 it actually
runs Windows 10 inside the hypervisor
because it has to run the hypervisor at
the lowest possible level
it's an incredibly efficient hypervisor
and even with the hypervisor running I
can flavor Forza Motorsport 7 on my
laptop as long as I wear headphones
because my god the fans allowed but and
I can't keep Forza Motorsport 7 on there
because it's 130 gigabytes but anyway I
can't run an emulator because the
Android emulator the official one runs
on Intel's hypervisor which is called
hacks em and hacks em is a level 0
hypervisor which can't run inside
another hypervisor the only hypervisor
that you can run inside hyper-v is
hyper-v so damn it and you go to stack
overflow and say stack overflow how do I
run the Android emulator and they say
turn off hyper-v and you're like but no
I'm not gonna like turn off hyper-v
reboot Windows and stop using docker for
as long as I'm building an Android
application and then turn it back on
again and Reaper it's just painful and
then someone's
I found a post going just use the
Microsoft I'm emulator for Android which
runs in hyper-v so I went and got that
but that doesn't work because Microsoft
it just doesn't you go create the
hyper-v thing and it goes yes I'm doing
it and then it just hangs so I can't
show you that I have another laptop if
you want to do mobile development to be
honest the best way of doing it is to
buy a Mac and use xamarin use Visual
Studio from Mac you can run a Mac empty
from the iOS emulator on there you can
hook it straight into an iPad or an
iPhone to do actual testing and because
it's a Mac you can run the Android
emulator on there because the Android
emulator for Mac is really bloody good
so yes if you want to do mobile
development just get a Mac okay have a
Windows PC as well for doing real
grown-up stuff but have a Mac for doing
mobile development so yes the other
thing you can do is that there is now
something called xamarin live player
which is actually something you install
onto an iPad or onto an Android device
and then you start it on the Android
device and you scan a QR code that it
generates for you in the visual studio
window and it just links them together
and then you just go deploy to that
Android device that I just linked you to
and it just puts your code across there
and you can actually you can change the
sample in Visual Studio and it instantly
updates on the device it's great it's
and you can do step debugging and all
this sort of stuff so that's actually
the easiest way to do it but still the
best you know if you want to do mobile
development you want to be doing it for
iOS if you want to do it for iOS you
need a Mac so get a MacBook it's a good
excuse so yes we had a uwp demo there so
then the other thing that people get
excited about and want to go and do is
game development and game development
traditionally has been C and C++ then
you have to learn DirectX or OpenGL and
get like hardcore into C and C++ code
and hook into engines and all this sort
of stuff
but just recently I have started
learning unity
with my daughter and unity is full
professional game engine it can do
pretty much everything that Unreal
Engine can do and it has sports too
scripting languages one is JavaScript No
and the other is c-sharp and it hooks
into Visual Studio or hooks into Ryder
or hooks into vs code and so you can
open things up in unity and let's see if
we can get this demo to work shall we
this definitely worked ten minutes ago
downstairs
this regularly I don't do anything in a
professional capacity it's just
ridiculous
okay here we go so this this is actually
just the the game from a tutorial book
that we're working through called
unity games by tutorial which is
available and cost forty quid I
absolutely recommend it but yes it gives
you the assets and all this sort of
stuff and you just create this game and
this is what I've been doing with my
daughter and if we go and we look at in
here we've got assets scripts and if I
click player controller you can see here
we've got some c-sharp code if I double
click it it opens it in Visual Studio
code which is what we've got it set up
to do and we'll get that to go away and
so yeah you can see here we just got
using unity engine you know a bunch of
classes that derive from monobehaviour
because this kind of came out of mono
stuff and then we just have standard
c-sharp code with generics and it
supports dotnet 2.0 at the moment but
they're bringing it up to standard so it
can become part of the net standard
ecosystem and it's going to support
c-sharp seven and seven point one and
seven point two but you you just that
all that c-sharp knowledge that you use
all day to get customers out of a
database and display them in a web
browser or in a WPF application you can
go home in the evening and use it to
blow up aliens or plant crops depending
on your particular preferences so yeah
that's you edit that code and if I just
click play we should go into play mode
so we are at the point in the tutorial I
love this it works with an Xbox
controller
it's a twin stick shooter so you can
point him in any direction and you're
running around like this and then he's
got that I'm pulling the trigger button
to shoot him we are at the point in the
demo where we have to do the thing that
when a bullet hits a bad guy the bad guy
explodes so at the moment the bad guy
does not explode he's just disappeared
off somewhere the camera in this is
actually worse than the camera in Tomb
Raider 3
but I need to fix that but yes this this
took us we did this got this far in a
weekend with this book and it was just a
couple of hours on Saturday and a couple
of hours on Sunday and and it just works
and you can do that that's using c-sharp
you can do it using JavaScript but don't
and you can pull in quite a lot of
things from the dotnet framework it
doesn't like new get at the moment but
once they pull it up to scratch and it
starts working with net standard then
you'll be able to use a net standard
library that's got some logic in it for
doing like communication with
leaderboards or something and then you
could use that in the unity application
you could use it in a xamarin
application in your iOS or Android game
you can just you know you could write a
unity application that pulls in the
system dot data dot sequel client
library and talks to a sequel database
so that when you have to do your
database cleanup you make them all
appear as robot tables and you run
around shooting the tables yeah that
sounds good do you ever see that was
someone did a fork of doom where all the
processes on the UNIX box were
represented as demons and they had their
process ID number floating over their
heads and if you did if you shot a demon
with the rocket launcher it did kill
minus 9 so yes so that's cool
unity they work very closely with
Microsoft they're like a Microsoft super
platinum titanium coated diamund partner
or something so unity is currently the
easiest way to write applications for
hololens and now we have mixed reality
coming along we've got Windows mixed
reality and you can go and into curries
and just pick up a standard virtual
reality headset I think the cheapest one
is three hundred quid the Acer one is
chunky and heavy but it works and you
can start creating these mixed reality
experiences that's gonna be just huge
over the next 10 years we've got
magically coming out this year developer
kits and you're gonna be able to use
unity and therefore dotnet and c-sharp
to build all these experiences at which
point it suddenly starts to make more
sense that you want to include system
sequal clients into your unity
application because maybe what you want
to do is pull order statistics out of
the database and render them floating on
top of somebody's desk and if they want
to zoom in on a particular region they
can reach out with their hands and go
like this this technically is the reason
I've given my wife why I'm learning
unity and need to buy a mixed reality
headset she bought it so you know that
works for me
so yes if you haven't had a chance to
play with unity it's completely free
until you get to the point where you
have a game that you want to publish and
start charging people money for so
building an Android version of a game we
rode an iOS version of the game you have
to pay for the professional license but
it's a subscription thing and it's like
20 bucks a month it's really not very
much and then there's another tier that
you have to go up to if your game makes
more than a lot of money in the course
of a year but it's that is the point at
which you would be going this is my job
now I make games and so you would be
able to afford that in theory so you can
go to unity 3d comm and download that
and start playing with it anytime you
like I've just done the demo and I would
like to properly credit the lead
developer on this project that's sir
those are my kids that's my daughter
Willow dressed as Ray she is 11 years
old and she is the only person I have
ever pair programmed with where I
haven't gone oh give me the beguine
keyboard at any point during the process
she wrote all the code she filled in all
the values in unity she is really
amazingly smart she's going to go out to
be a much better programmer than I am we
hope so yes and the little ones Ben and
he likes to build things out of
cardboard and then break them and we
have we've got a new project did anyone
play disney infinity or Skylanders sort
of a - your kids play it so the you know
the toys to life games that you see in
Toys R Us and game and places like that
you get little plastic toys and they've
got an NFC chip in the bottom and you
have a base that plugs into your xbox or
your PlayStation you put
character on the base and then it
appears in the game and you can start
using it and running around and my
little boy Ben was hugely into Disney
infinity
I mean obsessed with it because it had a
building mode bit like Minecraft and you
get components and builds your own
levels and we do this hide-and-seek
thing where you pick something up and go
and hide it somewhere and then the other
person have to go and find it which he
came up with and which Nintendo have
just released as a mode for Super Mario
Odyssey so I'm thinking game designer
and then Disney went we're not doing
this anymore
it's only making us 250 million dollars
a year that's not enough we're Disney so
they shot the development studio down
and so he's been going when I grow up
I'm going to make Disney infinity 4.0 so
when I get home I have waiting for me a
3d printer which I got on Kickstarter
last year and I've got a bag of NFC
chips which cost like 20 pH and a reader
writer that works with a Raspberry Pi
and I'm going to download pirated 3d
models of Disney characters off the
internet and we are going to use the 3d
printer to print the characters we're
going to stick the NFC chips in the
bottom and we're going to use unity 3d
to create our own version of Disney
infinity and that's that project for the
year and I'll be putting all that on
YouTube and if you've got kids who are
into tech or you think they'd like to
get into tech and they want to follow
along with that it's all gonna be
open-source we're gonna stick everything
up on YouTube and we're gonna start that
soon
so yes it's gonna be very amateurish and
rubbish but it will make us happy you
don't have to be amateurish and rubbish
though there are some not quite triple-a
but certainly double-a games coming out
now that are written in unity current
one is cuphead has anyone played cop
head yeah it's hard isn't it
it's like proper old-school 1980s video
game heart that was written in unity
stardew valley that was written in unity
a completely different style of game
that was written in unity as well and
superhot was written at a game jam the
original idea for superhot was written
the game jam that's written in unity as
well one thing I learned about while
kind of researching this and looking at
superhot is there is a plugin for unity
that you can get from the asset store
called pro builder which actually lets
you build your models so you don't have
to like use blender or 3ds max or
anything
like that you can actually just create a
cube and then chip away at it and turn
it into what you want inside the unity
interface so that's their pro builder
that's free there's a pro version so pro
builder pro so yes
you know we're creating kind of fairly
ganky rubbish things but we're hoping to
get better but people are using this to
create proper games that you can
download on Steam that they charge you
20 quid for and you kind of go yet that
was worth 20 quid and it's not just
unity 3d unity 3ds the most mature game
engine the supports c-sharp but there's
a game engine called Godot which is open
source which has its own language but
that in the next version they've got
alpha support for using C sharp as the
scripting language
there's mono game which is fully open
source mono based game design language
that's pretty good that's that's mature
and people build stuff with that and
Unreal Engine which is now open source
and you can download Unreal Engine
itself from github and build it on your
machine as long as you've got 64 gigs of
ram spare but there is a mono Unreal
Engine plugin that lets you use C sharp
as your kind of game logic in AI and
everything for unreal as well so you can
do all that sort of stuff and then we go
everything else that's going on in the
world of dotnet at the moment because
dotnet core means we can now write
applications on Windows and Mac and
we've got cross-platform editors we've
got Visual Studio for Mac which is
pretty good
you've got Ryder which is from JetBrains
and you can run that on Windows Mac and
Linux and it's pretty much the same
experience on all of them
you've got Visual Studio code which runs
on all three platforms and is pretty
much the same experience in all of them
we can compile our applications to run
on traditional Intel AMD 32-bit and
64-bit but now we can compile it to run
on arm as well so you can take your
dotnet core asp net core application and
stick it on a raspberry pi and just bung
that in the corner and run it you can
write Internet of Things stuff to run on
Arduino boards and tiny little maker
boards and so forth and now there's even
a library that lets you use CUDA
instructions from inside your c-sharp
code so if you've got something
really parallel that you need to do like
AI processing that sort of stuff you can
directly access the CUDA cores on your
run NVIDIA GPU we can take this code
that we've written in dotnet and we can
run it inside docker containers and we
can publish the docker containers to the
registry and then we can pull them down
into kubernetes clusters and we can run
them in kubernetes clusters and monitor
them with standard monitoring tools like
Prometheus and influx DB and that's
supported there's an app metrics library
for.net core that supports in flux and
Prometheus and all these cloud native
kind of technologies so all those modern
ways of doing everything we're finally
caught up with we don't have to go home
god how much is it going to cost us to
deploy a Windows server with 16 cores
and it's sort of deploy a linux server
with 8 calls and run mate core on it we
can run so azure and AWS and Google
Cloud would have all got really good
first-class support not only for all
their platform as a service things like
dynamo DB or s3 storage or table storage
or BigTable or whatever it might be if
you use Google Cloud right and you're
using the SDK stuff to talk to the
Google services you're using code that
John Skeet wrote which means your
application is by default one of the
best applications in the world because
it's got John skeet code in it right so
yes not only that though each of these
platforms has its own server lists
architecture so you've got a zoo of
functions AWS lambda and Google's thing
and those all support dotnet core to
point
oh now as well so you can write c-sharp
code just to just a method a class with
a method and then publish it into lambda
or into Azure functions and then just
send it information trigger it and it's
just you have parameters and it gets
called and yeah that's really cool
pretty soon you'll be able to do native
compile that and then throw it up there
and then it'll start up as quickly as
you saw the slighty thing start up there
and best of all all of this stuff all
this dotnet core and asp net core and
all these cool things that they're doing
are happening in the open on github
fully open source if you're going
through the code and going I can see how
to do that a better way or there's a
mistake there or whatever then you can
fork it and fix it and send them a pull
request or you can do what Adam Ralph
does which is to fix the whitespace
formatting and
the pull request still gets your name on
the list of contributors come to PubCon
if you want to hear more about that from
Adam himself so yes given all this cool
stuff that you can do with dotnet I'm
not saying there's nothing else out
there there's of any interest I'm
learning rust rust is great
I like rust there are things that I
would use rust for I'm learning other
things all the time learning other
languages is a great way to learn to use
your primary language better in a lot of
cases I never understood the whole
concept of yield in AI enumerables until
I used Ruby and had block it orators not
coming oh this is what C sharps doing
with forage so yes there's lots of stuff
out there and it's good to keep
interested and to broaden your horizons
and to play with things but there's
absolutely no reason to leave anything
because it's an incredibly dynamic
ecosystem it's an incredibly dynamic
community it's full of wonderful people
who are doing very exciting things
there's an endless amount of stuff you
could do with it for the rest of your
life and never run out of things and I
love it and I hope I've managed to
express some of how much I love it all
of you guys and maybe send you away with
something that you gonna go I'm gonna
try that tomorrow if not sadhya thanks
very much for coming I'll see you next
year
Cheers bike
[Applause]